[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est la grand-messe du football
américain et comme chaque année le
support est aussi le spectacle de la
démesure
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
des centaines de millions de litres de
bière consommée et beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent destinés au paris sportifs
de paris sportifs triomphe
[Musique]
qui génère le plus de Paris chez le taux
Québec c'est qu'il sera possible de
parier sur à peu près tout ce soir du
vainqueur du match jusqu'à la couleur du
gettering qui traverse sur la tête de
l'entraîneur de l'équipe gagnante
on ressent vraiment un engouement là
chez les parieurs sportifs il faut dire
que la légalisation des paris simple par
Ottawa en 2021 a eu un effet direct sur
les ventes de l'auto-québec qui depuis
sont en croissance d'année en année
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui a permis à
Maxime le gris de vivre presque
exclusivement des paris sportifs mais
pour le Superbowl il préfère jouer
prudence et miser un petit montant sur
la finale du Super Bowl ça va être pour
le plaisir de mettre un peu de piquant
en regardant le match il y a jamais rien
sur c'est toujours très complexe ça se
déroule jamais comme prévu de l'argent
et de plus en plus facile les publicités
sont nombreuses sur internet en faisant
de la promotion de ses activités on est
en train en quelque sorte de banaliser
les jeux de hasard et d'argent incluant
les paris sportifs on sait que c'est pas
des activités banales elle insiste sur
l'importance de la prévention il y a
très peu de autour des méfaits et autour
de l'encadrement et de la régulation des
jeux de hasard et d'argent en ligne
actuellement on ne fait pratiquement
rien même si il est facile de parier en
ligne que les sites Internet qui se
consacrent à l'activité et son nombreux
le taux Québec rappelle que son site de
paris sportifs et le seul et l'unique
qui soit légal dans la province ici qui
me permettrait au Canada Montréal